good afternoon everyone my name is Dr
Miller and the SCP we're going to be
looking at today is SCP
2918 object class
safe special containment procedures SCP
918 is stored in Hangar 2 at Foundation
site9 the control panel should be
monitored for new messages every 24
hours at a minimum the airframe of SCP
2918 is to be stored unfueled and
unarmed at all times regular psychiatric
evaluations are to be administered every
two weeks by Dr a specialist in child
psychology with experience in anxiety
treatment description SCP 2918 is an
incomplete mq1 predator on Mann aerial
vehicle Suite consisting of one airframe
one Ground Control System GCS and one
primary satellite link communication
Suite currently disabled the GCS is
configured into four cockpits to
communicate with up to four airframes
but burn damage and ordinance
fragmentation has rendered three out of
four cockpits inoperable the remaining
control Suite designated A2 communic
Ates via Wireless tactical data link
with the only remaining drone SCP 2918
is capable of generating messages on the
GCS systems Monitor and has displayed
significantly enhanced feedback control
the system has been observed as
communicating its Diagnostics in simple
English occasionally producing visual
aids in the form of bitmap images the
nature of these messages imply that the
airframe is self-aware foundation
testing has placed the airframes
intelligent and emotional maturity as on
par with that of a 10 to 12year old
child SCP 2918 is largely dosel but
displays symptoms of anxiety and
post-traumatic stress disorder including
nightmares and
flashbacks aside from its apparent
sapience and ability to communicate SCP
2918 displays no anomalous properties
the Drone is an mq 1B predator of
unmodified build with standard hard
points for payload delivery
SCP 2918 was brought to the foundation's
attention following incident SCP 2918
Kato during which the airframe while
under control of USAF Personnel refused
to respond to commands and attacked its
own operators in the process the GCS was
damaged and the other airframes
eventually crashed not being able to
receive commands to return and being
unable to refuel their reck displayed no
anomalous properties and were eventually
SC though SCP 2918 has not displayed any
independent motions since incident SCP
2918 kto it is stored unarmed and
unfueled as a standard safety precaution
no experimentation involving fueling SCP
2918 is to be undertaken at this
time interview log SCP 2918 51 note all
psychiatric interviews are conducted
through the GCS control panel as such
SCP 2918 is rendered as UAV A2 and Dr is
rendered as pilot
A2 good morning 2918 this is
Dr good morning
doctor how are you feeling today bad
dreams about
Dad is he
okay Captain kto is
safe what were the dreams like
fire there were little kids and they
were hurt real
bad did I do that no you did
not but it was real was it it your dream
was what we call a flashback 201918 you
were reliving a Trauma from the past but
that doesn't mean it's real
now it still feels
real
even though I know it
isn't would you like to draw pictures
today yes please
doctor interview log SCP 2918 kto
1 interview dated 19 20 2 days after SC
SCP 2918 displayed anomalous properties
interviewer research a prior service
member and Foundation Personnel
stationed at a nearby AFB interviewed
Captain Derek kto USAF drone
pilot when did you first begin to
recognize 201918 anomalous properties
I'm not sure please clarify for the
records listen you work on these things
for 12 plus hours a day for weeks
sometimes months we would talk about
them like they were real people why
would you do that Bor mostly you're
stuck in the GCS for 12 hours a day you
get familiar with the machines over time
and you
start I'll refresh my memory what's the
word for when you assign human
characteristics to something anamorphism
sure you start treating them like people
B2 had a slight Crook in the wing not
enough to render it IOP but enough that
you had to compensate for it when you
were turning so we called him a grumpy
old man like he had a foot stuff
like that so you and your fellow Pilots
assigned personalities to the drones not
intentionally we just kind of complained
about them to be honest you know a1's
lagging a little he wants to do his own
thing B one's camera is off she wants to
have a Kodak moment with that Sunset
instead of the HJY were after what
personality was assigned to airframe
A2 innocence for one reason or another
A2 always got less action than all the
other drones and we eventually started
joking about it being a virgin or a
little girl did the system display any
anomalous properties before the event
like I said they had their own problems
we didn't think it was out of the
ordinary well except maybe that we
weren't putting enough effort into the
maintenance most Crews wouldn't let a
crook in the wing or a laggy turbine go
on for so long but we just chalked it up
to a high Ops Tempo the colonel wanted
us to take them on missions practically
every day barly enough time for us to
sleep and eat and refuel then we'd be
back home can you describe for us the
events on 17
201 Captain kot's demeanor shifts
notably during this portion of the
interview though he appears
uncomfortable his face is expressionless
and maintains strict military
bearing yes sir on the 17th we undertook
a night mission
in we were looking for an Insurgent
leader in the area our night monitoring
was poor but we believed we had found
him in the presence of several civilians
we asked for Mission clarification and
were told to proceed regardless of the
civilian Presence at the time I was
operating airframe A2 she refused to
fire when you say refused you mean I
issued the command to Fire and A-frame
A2 did not fire all systems displayed
green and there was no mechanical
failure I issued the command to fire a
second time and A2 still refused we
shuffled tasking and I began to return
for maintenance while B2 took the shot
B2 confirmed casualties on the ground at
which point we we realized several of
the Dead were
children Captain kado pauses to take
several deep breaths he is noted as
assuming the seated position of
attention his account of events nearly
word for word matches his written
statement from his judicial
[Applause]
hearing A2 began to accelerate on its
return even though no command had been
issued to do so it continued to
accelerate well beyond safe flying
speeds we had taken nearly 90 minutes on
approach and A2 made the return journey
in
45 while A2 was returning we analyzed
the ground and realized that our Target
was not among the casualties at this
point we began to call into doubt
whether or not he had even been present
at the
location we radioed up to command post
asking for further details and Mission
instructions and we ready to declar the
mission a total failure at this point A2
completed its return Journey but refused
to slow when given commands to do
so Captain kado begins to hyperventilate
researcher offers Captain kotto a glass
of water and is told he can sited a
captain kado accepts the glass of water
but refuses to leave the position of
attention
otherwise A2 fire two Stingers at the
GCS one impacted the cockpit for B2 but
did not detonate killing the pilot
instantly the other landed nearby and
detonated wounding second Lieutenant the
pilot for B1 and first lieutenant the
pilot for A1 I removed the pilots from
the GCS which had caught fire
while requesting medical attention for
the wounded A2 landed itself on the
strip with no input while medical and
fire Personnel put out the GCS and be
began to treat the wounded
Pilots kado leaves the position of
attention shielding his eyes with his
hands
lived did
not no further questions at this time
thank you
Captain closing statement Captain kto
was treated with class B amnestics and
soon received an honorable discharge
from military service his chain of
command and Personnel involved in taking
his state were also issued Class B
amnestics up to Brigadier General who is
to monitor missions for further
deviations of this nature and report
them to Foundation Personnel if
discovered addendum message received
from SCP 2918 dated 27
201 this date coincides with Captain
kot's date of honorable
discharge that isn't coming back is
this concludes today's lecture thank you
for listening if indeed you still are
and you're all dismissed
[Music]
goodbye I would like to give a special
thank you to
zargaran o crop guy B sep Rowan
O'Brien Jack wall James
SAA Lost Boy
segnar your local Foundation agent
zazan worthy fire cubster Dean
dingis braded
Peach
kak Mr
duuk s VOS osiro Vision Grim nearer
extra moments
123 Swift raw and
ABY if you would like a special thank
you at the end of each of my videos and
some other cool stuff as well visit
patreon.com slthe vulgan thank
you